[Music]
hi i'm keith massbeck
keith is a former director of
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance integration for the us
army
today we'll be breaking down clips about
satellites from tv and film
working in tandem enemy of the state
okay satellite imagery coming through
roger that patch visual my location give
me real-time imagery coverage at la
3855 long 77 0-0 first of all i do
mapping and geospatial stuff for a
living the fact that this guy
knows the latitude and longitude of
where he is apparently at any place on
the earth
is pretty impressive roger that only a
minute on satellite visual over
jack black apparently has access to
satellites 300 miles up going 17
500 miles an hour they're not waiting
around for jack black to tell him what
to do
everybody move he just jumped to the
adjacent building
a satellite's good for a lot of things
it's just not
responsive in a way that you'd use for a
foot chase
suspect building on colombia
another thing that's remarkable here is
the magnitude of this operation
they appear to have pulled in nsa nga
nro fbi and the local police and i'll
tell you short of going after someone at
the level of
osama bin laden you're just not going to
see an operation of this magnitude we
were there
for technical support satellite
communications
battleship every 24 hours our station in
hawaii will transmit a signal to landsat
7 our deep orbiting satellite so i'm
amused in this scene by the mention
of landsat i actually personally sit on
the landsat
advisory group so landsat while a
fantastic
series of satellites over time has
nothing to do with anything in this
scene because it's an earth imaging
spacecraft has nothing to do with
communications with other
galaxies our station in hawaii will
transmit a signal we're talking about
referencing a facility in hawaii that
does deep space
tracking those are radio telescopes that
are there receiving signals from outer
space generally
much less than transmitting them please
prepare to bear witness
to the making of history i think when
you put it all together there's just
like a mishmash of stuff going on this
scene they're sort of all just jumbling
it all together in a way that
really doesn't make sense it's a joke
right lidar
bad boys too this is taffy's compound oh
cra hooked us up huh yeah this lighter
laser technology even shows his escape
tone
so lidar stands for light detection and
ranging which is the use of an
active sensor shooting out light photons
and what it creates is a 3d
depiction that we call a point cloud for
instance if you're able to get
lidar into a window those photons bounce
around and kind of paint the room so you
can understand the size of the room and
what things are in a room
all super helpful as you plan an
operation we are severely screwed if we
don't blow up this security world
before we make a move so in this
particular clip you can see that they've
used lidar perhaps from the top of the
building across the street
and they've got a great depiction of the
house it's taffy's compound
intelligence is at its best when it's
combining
multiple sources so here you've got the
infrared
the contour mapping and the lidar when
you bring it all together it really
tells
a cohesive picture we got everything
that we need to take this dude
getting it wrong arrested development we
got something
and you're gonna do time for it those
are the pictures they're all over the
news
those are balls i mean this scene is
certainly an example
of absolutely getting it wrong and at
the end of the day
analysts are human and analysts do make
mistakes bias had inadvertently
photographed himself while learning to
use his camera phone
this close they always look like
landscape context of course is
critically important
generally you'd start from a very wide
shot and then you'd zoom
in to a specific area that you're
looking for something so you have that
context to begin with
are you serious almost always the weight
of a decision
homeland i want the habitation's within
75 meters of the target
well obviously anybody inside the
farmhouse would be collateral damage
in this scene we see carrie a cia
officer
working to assess collateral damage i
feel a lot better if you weren't so
blind on such a short clock
one of the things that i think is
interesting is her fervent desire
for just a little more time or a little
more information in the intelligence
business we
sometimes refer to this as analysis
paralysis we always want a little more
information
we always want one more picture but at
the end of the day the perfect
intelligence delivered one minute too
late
is absolutely worthless we got lucky
jack tornado satellite
and that's the location right there so
there's a couple problems here i think
it refers to
nato satellites nato satellites while
nato member nations
have imaging satellites nato itself
doesn't actually control
any satellites another problem here i
can immediately tell that
that's not a satellite image that's a
drone image and you can tell because
the system is loitering and satellites
don't loiter where are the f-15s
uh they're buzzing the border they can
be on the target in 60 seconds one thing
we see across many of these movies and
tv shows
is a lot of similar looking operation
centers or ground stations we were able
to track the building at mid-altitude
orbit right where we can't touch a
possible high-value target no idea what
they're doing so actually i've had a
long-standing
personal theory that we build our
operations centers we build our
ground stations to look like the movies
we look at those and we think wow that's
what it should look like and then we
replicate it ourselves
denial and deception billions all the
big funds are using satellite images
how many cars are in the parking lot of
walmart indicates how big a quarter
they're gonna have
i mean that that's just really
interesting because that's happening
i don't think that people necessarily
realize that there are
commercial remote sensing firms with
satellites and that
companies on wall street and hedge funds
are taking advantage
of those types of images to make
decisions about
trades in january 2016 krakow's tone on
china changed
more bullish omniscient the analyst
says something's changed in the tone of
this person's public statements
let me see if what they're saying
matches what i can see from satellite
images
they knew they were being watched so the
trucks started moving
a show for the satellites factories are
fake
it's a shell to milk investors denial
and deception
is both an art and a science from the
time that we could see from above
people on the ground knew that they had
kind of two choices they could either
hide deny or they could attempt to
deceive
make something look different than it
really is and that
continues to this day this is going to
be fun high stakes mission
zero dark 30.
[Music]
we just crossed the border now entering
pakistan the long-term
hunt for osama bin laden was one of the
most
significant things i've ever been
involved in
so what you're seeing here is an
underlying base map
foundation data that's probably being
fed by
signals intelligence data beacons from
the aircraft themselves so you're able
to track them
is down this hunt over time for osama
bin laden was
always a very high priority for the
intelligence community and the defense
department
thousands of satellite images were taken
over time
when tips indicated that we might have a
bead
on where he was located as the community
watched this facility
some things started to stand out it was
a
very very secure compound it had 12 foot
walls on one side there was someone who
was affectionately known
as the pacer it was someone who came out
into the walled garden
and re-entered the facility there was a
suspicion among the analysts who were
working this
day in and day out that in fact that was
osama bin laden
it might surprise people to know that
there was not indeed
certainty that we had in fact killed
osama bin laden until
there were pictures and ultimately they
confirmed it with dna testing
satellite disruption independence day
let's say that you want to coordinate
with spaceships on different sides of
the earth
i couldn't send a direct signal right
you talking about line of sight so line
of sight in radio communications
absolutely
is a thing you need satellites to relay
that signal
in order to reach each ship most often
what satellite operators do
is have their satellites talk to
multiple ground stations around the
earth well i found a signal
hidden inside our own satellite system
there are certainly
reasons that information from satellites
gets disrupted
it could be hardware or software or
firmware on the satellite itself
and even solar weather space weather
they're using our own satellites against
us
infrared imagery behind enemy lines you
think the pilot transmission came from
here
so we should stop it like that satellite
looked like something like you'd make
out of a lego set
now this is imagery from a norfolk
grumman relay satellite downloading
through the jana processing center in
stuttgart
we've hot wired it for heat image the
next thing that happens is that they
somehow have
hot wired a satellite that doesn't even
belong to them to use it for something
it wasn't even built to do
this isn't strictly legal sir they would
have lots of assets available for a
search and rescue operation
that's very high priority
[Music]
that's burnett yes sir infrared imagery
is quite valuable at night you can see
things
that are emitting heat you can see a
vehicle which has recently been used
because you're going to be able to see
that the engine is still hot you
wouldn't necessarily use a satellite to
look for somebody
a satellite being 300 miles away it's
kind of tough to get the
heat signature of a single human being
what's going on he's down
you've been shot so there's some
confusion in the command center here
why isn't he moving when we see behavior
that doesn't add up that doesn't make
sense
you know those are indicators to us that
we've got to use
a different approach to get more
information to explain what's going on
get right on him
[Music]
this is a great example of where you'd
want to use everything at your disposal
you'd be using electro optical
you'd be using infrared you'd be using
synthetic aperture radar
anything you could to pull things
together to give yourself a better
picture
i want intel on this situation
recognizing a nuclear site
the west wing this picture was taken by
an sr-71 during
a routine flyover in the gulf the
chairman of the joint chiefs refers
to the sr-71 as taking part in a routine
flyover of the gulf and yes
we are interested in many areas of the
world and we are looking at
many areas routinely this is bashar
and this is what looks to me like the
early days of construction on a light
water reactor
the location of bashir actually is a
site
in iran so that's interesting light
water is what's used for nuclear
reactors and the iranians have
contracted the russians to build them a
light water reactor for that purpose
something that looks like the
development of a nuclear facility is
certainly going to get our
attention i'd compare it to what you do
with your physician
the earlier you catch something the more
options your doctors have to take care
of it
it's the same in intelligence the sooner
i can show a decision maker that
something's happening
the more certainty i can give them about
it taking a look at the image
specifically
it refers to the latitude and longitude
as two numbers they'd probably be better
off with that guy in the alley in the
will smith movie
flat 3855 re-tasking the satellites
patriot games unless you authorize us to
re-test those satellites so we can get a
look before they're overhead from the
side
we are never gonna know which camp
they're at there's always more
requests for satellite imagery from our
spy satellites than we're able to meet
so we make a plan
to be the most efficient collection that
we can put together do you have any idea
how big a deal it is to re-task those
satellites
yeah occasionally high-priority things
disrupt that plan
and so we re-task those satellites to
get that thing we need that is a higher
priority than what we were planning to
do
so it's not trivial but it's normal
keep at it then mismatched expectations
archer you want me to look for what a
station wagon
clean the impending massive heart attack
out of your ears
in this scene we see a really
interesting tension between someone who
is responsible for satellite imagery and
some people who desperately want some
information
a station wagon in all of texas it's
incumbent upon those of us who are in
the satellite imaging business
to be able to explain to commanders and
decision makers
and people who aren't used to using them
exactly what they can and can't do
hey is that it no that's not it because
they often come in
with unrealistic expectations based on
movies and tv points delivering bad news
a bridge too far splendid view of the
dutch countryside
can't see any wait a moment sorry it's a
lot clearer in the next picture
the intelligence officer is showing as
commander that there were tanks where
they didn't think there would be any
yes i i shouldn't worry about them
let's say you see that they are tanks
what i think so important about this
clip
is the fact that the intelligence
officer has to deliver things that he
knows the commanders aren't going to
want to hear you seriously consider
asking us to cancel the biggest
operation mounted since d-day
because of three photographs it's tough
to tell commanders things that don't
comport with their plan
as an intelligence officer you're
delivering things in an
unbiased way with your best judgment and
sometimes it just
isn't what the commander wants to hear
this time the party's on
calculating collateral damage eye in the
sky
if my target can calculate is coming in
under 50
for collateral damage on the girl do you
think you can get approval your end
yes i do decisions around calculating
collateral damage
are dynamic and they're ongoing if we
put the payload here or here
or or maybe here well then we could
guarantee the target fatality or but we
could reduce the collateral
certainly as an intelligence
professional you want to understand that
pattern of life what normally happens
around this house what happens in the
neighborhood around this house
there is a 45 to 65 possibility of
fatality 65
yes i need that calculation to be below
50 they're talking in super strict
percentages here there is an absolute
art and science to
to weaponeering to understanding the
damage that a weapon is going to cause
the angle that it's going to come in the
amount of explosive in the weapon
and then using tools based on imagery
based on maps
and based on 3d models of the facility
to understand precisely
what the collateral damage is going to
be sergeant you need to make this work
there's clearly a subtext here an
undertone that the analyst is being
pressured to change his call to meet a
criteria
that was pre-decided there are many
lives at risk these types of things
can happen and it comes down to moral
courage it comes down to
being able to stand your ground rather
than allow
people to to sort of nudge or change
your judgment to
fit a specific situation satellite hack
diamonds are forever
[Music]
wait something's happening in this scene
what happens is a nefarious actor a bad
guy
takes over a satellite something's taken
over the guidance system
it says if it had a will of its own we
are completely incentivized to ensure
that no one can
get into the data stream take over the
satellite
or hack it in any way that's critically
important to us
and we work very hard to make sure that
that simply can't happen
it looked like their budget was a
hundred bucks is what it looked like
that's not a damn thing we can do about
it at the moment i mean as hokey as some
of the things in this scene might be
the depiction of the satellite
deployment itself isn't
really completely out of bounds
perhaps the solar panels might not
deploy until after separation
from the second stage if that's what it
was but otherwise i mean it's sort of
close
well that's a neat trick private
satellites die another day
imagine being able to grow crops the
year round bringing an end to hunger
imagine a second sun
shining like a diamond in the sky in
this scene we
we see the the bad guy here trying to
replicate the sun
which seems like a pretty bad idea let
there be light
so the first thing that strikes me in
this scene is that is one
massive space structure it took years to
launch and assemble the international
space station
this is something that kind of looks
like it's on that scale you have no idea
how much icarus is about to change your
world
not everyone is a responsible actor in
space
some governments are irresponsible and
some corporations are irresponsible so
on one hand
space is big right big space little
satellite but if there is no
traffic cop if there is no space traffic
management
if there isn't a shared idea of what we
call space domain awareness or space
situational awareness
there's really an opportunity a
potential for a lot of bad stuff to
happen on orbit
knocked out of orbit austin powers gold
member
sir dr evil's not bluffing one of our
satellites is falling out of orbit
when it comes to this scene just
sticking to the satellite stuff
what's interesting here is this is a war
fighting domain and that's the recent
creation of the united states space
force
several countries on earth have
demonstrated an ability
to do asap anti-satellite operations
in fact the united states did it first
by firing a missile from a
u.s air force aircraft in 1985.
[Music]
you know one thing we see a lot of is
satellite zooming through space
they all look different they've all got
different things bolted on and different
configurations
but in fact in low earth orbit they are
kind of zooming
they're going about 18 000 miles an hour
300 miles up
so they're kind of moving satellite
sabotage
space force epsilon should be passing
right about now oh yeah there's a spark
beautiful wow so it struck me
immediately in this clip as
as general nerd is talking to his
science advisor is that he apparently
has the world's best
telescope right outside his house
i got it he's able to see an incredible
detail what's happening on orbit
wait is that a second spark
while this looks like some silly
depiction of something happening on
orbit
it's actually not completely out of the
realm of the possible
space command commander general
dickinson recently acknowledged that the
chinese have the capability potentially
to quote unquote
grapple another satellite with a an arm
close-up surveillance homeland
who's here do we recognize him i think
he's just a kid from the village
well he's definitely spotted us so the
type of
uav drone or remotely piloted aircraft
that's depicted here
is a predator b a predator b can operate
as high as 50
000 feet it's not particularly loud and
in fact you'd normally want to operate
it in a way that your adversary wouldn't
know that they were under surveillance
as i watched this and the idea of is
this realistic
i suppose if there was some reason
operationally that they brought the
aircraft down a little lower or brought
it in a little closer than they might
normally do
it's possible that the young man could
have heard it or seen it and looked up
in the sky
this reminds me of a scene from men in
black when agent k
is sort of having a moment keeping an
eye on his wife with some sort of
surveillance activity
[Music]
the scene from men in black looks more
like it's something from a cctv camera
that might be on some sort of really
tall pole versus the much more realistic
depiction we saw
in homeland we're bulletproof on this
outsmarting surveillance
body of lies
in this scene the bad guys are
understanding that they might be under
surveillance
[Music]
which one do you want us to follow i
think what what's important here to
understand
is something we talk about in the
intelligence community is protecting
sources and methods we don't want people
to understand
what we can do when we can do it and how
we can do it
because that gives them an edge that
gives them the ability to think about
how they might be able to defeat that
advantage real intelligence operations
they remain secret forever
conclusion i think the most important
thing i'd want to leave the audience
with
is to take a look with a skeptical eye
think about what's
actually possible think about what looks
like it makes sense
because there's such a mix here of
things that are
absolutely plausible and things that are
absolutely never going to happen
and they're completely unrealistic thank
you wired